have you ever used your gay privilege
card
well on other gay men probably
i mean i just how much do you want to
know
[Laughter]
an intrusive question uh um
what do you mean
is there not some sort of privilege it's
like
a free extra shot at starbucks or
whatever what do you get never no never
that um
uh
i think i know what you're getting at uh
as it were are there things i'm able to
say and do that a straight person
wouldn't yes
no
uh that would be the case if i was very
left-wing
or remotely left-wing
for sure
but uh since i'm
i've not got the correct views
so you're basically straight
i'm i'm an honorary straight if not
worse
i'm even worse straight
sexual
it's that bad chris
it's that disgusting and reprehensible
that
my views have ungained me uh and i don't
have a minority card
uh that is actually the case
uh it honestly is it's the same with
women right-wing women and not really
women they have their woman card taken
away
uh anyone who's right-wing and gay isn't
actually gay they had that gay card
taken away and so on um
and i just said that occasionally i hear
people saying oh well douglas only gets
away with sayings on himself he's saying
he's gay
i think they they don't really
understand that's not the case um i say
what i think and i defend it
pretty vigorously i think usually
and uh
i've never felt that i've had any extra
leeway because i happen to be gay partly
because it's something i don't talk
about very much because i don't think
it's very interesting and i don't want
to bang on about uninteresting things
but um but also because i i just i i i
don't believe in i
may have said this to you before in
private or in public but i don't believe
in the speaking as a
prefix i mean i just don't believe in
that and even before i could identify
what i didn't like about it i didn't
like it i didn't like the sort of person
and you stood up and say um so my
parents were from peru and honduras and
i am a bisexual
i don't care get to the point
you know doesn't matter to me
stop it
um and people only ever did it if they
had traits that they thought meant that
they should grab the microphone
is there not some validity to
the experience that everybody has which
gives them a unique perspective on the
world yeah but that's endless
but everyone has that everyone's got a
unique perspective
goddammit i mean every person in the
world has a unique perspective
identical twins each have unique
perspectives from each other
that's not a very interesting
observation
i mean it's
we all have a unique perspective now you
know is a person who has been oppressed
in some way have they got a particularly
interesting perspective well on their
oppression sure and on subjects relating
to it but not on anything else
um
and i shouldn't take your advice on
accounting or
macroeconomics or something they're
definitely not
running around a million miles and i'm
trying to give you financially speaking
as a gay man yeah speaking as a gay man
you need to invest in isis i mean
um
no it's it's just
all that sort of ridiculous validity
seeking uh i'm not in favor of but no i
suppose there are some people who
who
think that i
get away with saying certain of the
things i do about highly contentious
issues for some
they try to find some reason for it but
it's definitely not because of the fact
i haven't be gay because they say in my
own experience it's never been
um anything i've benefited from uh
career-wise certainly hasn't
occasionally been something i've
suffered for in a certain to a certain
extent or i don't really like to think
in those terms and certainly don't like
to moan
which makes me an unusual figure in this
era of course what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace